okay hi everyone another live stream
today we are looking at another piece of
uh Wolfram language design reviewing for
version 13.3 I hope
um
this is the service deploy framework
so the basic idea of service deploy is
there is an external running service
out there and we are going to Lodge
something with that service
which is essentially a callback to our
system that a fair characterization
color
um not in the case of what replication
server Worth or web engine in that case
it's lodged there and that thing that
external thing contains a wall from
ending itself so it doesn't need to talk
to cloud or anything like that
okay so it doesn't need a callback
necessarily so it's it's simply so
you're saying
that this is by the way absolutely crazy
that description there
what the heck does that mean
um
well I I kind of I I decided to mirror
what it says for cloud deploy so service
deployment instead of cloud deploy uh
Cloud object sorry so service deployment
is the cloud object of service deploy
so I know but but with that wording
it becomes kind of meaningless
now I don't remember what cloud deploy
says but but that says deploys expert to
an anonymous Cloud object that's very
different to an anonymous service
deployment I mean that that's a that's
completely different
because there's no employees expert to
service
yeah yeah putting Anonymous in there I
think it's yeah I know what the heck it
means that it's Anonymous I mean it's
it's like it's not a Twitter the bird
has been the bird has been um
not that necessarily deploying to
Twitter but I mean I'm just I'm thinking
of the Mask bird because it's Anonymous
and all that kind of thing never mind
it's a dog now the bird's gone
Bird is Gone
wow yeah musk changed the logo to the
Dogecoin but that that was uh belated
April's fall I think like uh okay I
thought that what I wondered about that
it seems like yeah I don't think I've
done the guy you know a Twitter is a
bird and yeah that's tough to
tough to overcome that well they've
changed into marker
he was just pumping up the Dogecoin
price probably for a weekend yeah yeah
right
um okay
so
okay so the example for Wolfman
application server Works how does this
have a I mean presumably in the
documentation Pages we'll do something
like we do for
um
uh
service connect and so on
that you know because on the service
connect page we have a list of actual
services with all their different
characteristics right
yeah and and was as a service page as
well uh which you see if you have the
was packlet installed
well you should see it anyway
I mean that's not the case right now but
I agree with you when we are moving this
stuff to to the main documentation and
not in the packlet okay but but then so
for service deploy the expectation is
that there will be a list of supported
external services
and that those initially are
um so so what do you deploy to a I'm I'm
so confused what do you deploy to both
an application server if you're
deploying an API for example do you
simply take is expert in that case API
function yes
yes so the the existing uh the thing
that I that I inherited from the was
group uh required an association as a
second argument where you had were
forced to specify where you would put
the resource what the endpoint was Etc
but we can do that like we do with Cloud
objects we can also generate that stuff
you don't want if you don't want to
specify it
okay let me give you an example okay
well I don't think that's quite as
obvious as you think
okay mail receiver function is something
that should be a service deployment
right now you can Cloud deploy a mail
receiver function and that's just wrong
okay and what does it run in the cloud
when it gets triggered
it has a callback to the cloud what it
runs look if you use mail receiver
function what it fundamentally has to
tell you is this is the email address
you've been you've been us assigned
okay it's got to tell you two things
it's it's a total hack what oh there we
go it doesn't even have to have a
function that that gets run when the
when email is received and that function
is to run in a cloud question mark yeah
it runs in the cloud okay but but it is
triggered by something that comes from
the mail a mail server
that's the point so what's happening
here this is a total hakalola I mean
this is a cloud object right with its
own uuid but it also so that you know
what the heck to do it gives you this
weird male toothpiece in here because
it's really going to return two things
that should be a service deployment yes
I know that's what I'm saying right so
because it's got to return two things
it's got to return where did it lodge
because they're two Anonymous things
it's creating one is the cloud object
and the other is the the hook into the
mail server
you see what I'm saying yeah yeah and
yeah when I mean while that's not
necessarily for Wars when we get to chat
Bots Etc I will show you what I think
that should be
okay so but by the way just in general
though should is service deploy of is
that like can you service deploy to war
from cloud and is that equivalent to
Cloud deploy
I think it should be no you can't but I
don't see why I I mean I can Implement
that in one line probably so yes right
yeah so I guess then that makes that
makes sense because then you could but
now there's a little bit of weirdness
with mail receiver function though
because then presumably you could
service deploy
to you could service deploy a male
receiver function to the cloud but then
you get back a service deployment object
just looked at Cloud object
maybe yeah no you shouldn't be able to
do that you shouldn't be able to do that
the the service department you have to
service deploy it to some mail to a mail
server okay
right
to something which is a
uh you know an anchor point for a mail
server I'm not quite sure what that
looks like I mean you know the answer
but if you want to do what if you want
to do it's done with the cloud right now
or the cloud is the Anchor Point for the
mail server presumably what you'd give
it is some sort of Cloud representation
sure of a mail server
yeah maybe you have some mail server
wrapper around it that makes it
unambiguous this is the cloud as a mail
server as opposed to just the cloud
right there's one thing I'm confused
about here is like
I don't know how it's implemented but
could you technically tell the cloud
listen to this pop or IMAP server which
is not at wolframcloud.com but it's at
something else here are my credentials
well then it has to be the cloud both
ways right
right now yes the server is a look this
is a mail server that sits next to the
cloud okay
it's not
it's a mail server that has a
relationship to the cloud and that has I
don't know exactly how it works here
let's see mail response function
to apply to respond to the sender okay
that's something different
okay so I mean we'd have to ask somebody
how this exact exactly implemented but
fundamentally it's a mail server that
sits in parallel to the cloud
and what happens is the mail server runs
what is it proc mail RC or something I
don't know exactly what it is but the
mail what's happening is the mail server
is calling the API in the cloud
see what I'm saying
and this is my belief that you could set
up any old mail server to do that
maybe I don't know but not many people
have
I I wonder if you could do that as
rather than as a mail server as a male
client so you you give our Cloud our
merely serial function the password to
your email we we checked your emails and
when something comes in we do something
okay that's a completely different thing
that's the mail server connect
functionality and I don't believe that
we have a Notifier mechanism but no one
can imagine that okay that works with
that's a whole different thing
but anyway I think okay that's mail
server connect
okay that's a thing for connecting to an
IMAP server for example I I forget what
kinds of servers are supported
um
okay
and then you can read your mail
get what I'm saying anyway I think it's
pretty clear what we're doing here the
main point is that in the case of uh
mail receiver function
the main main thing
what the heck is this
Cloud get a mail log oh I see I see
Cloud put to mail log okay I get it
right the the main thing here
is the deployment needs to return two
things the name of the cloud object
which is the proxy for the deployment
and the actual uh mail address and the
reason it needs the cloud object is
because if you're going to delete this
deployment you need to know where the
deployment is
did you see what I'm saying yeah and and
uh if you open up the service deployment
uh documentation page the idea is
deployment the idea is that it contains
an association and depending on what the
type of it is the name of it is then it
um I don't know if that link will work
because maybe it still links to the data
um so so like right now I specified what
it does for over application server
Wolfram engine maybe name is not the
right key for that but we could have
like this be different for all things
and this display differently for all
four when we call it service
we could call it service
that the yeah the problem is that as
it's implemented right now service was
what is URL now which is honestly kind
of weird
nothing's wrong yes
uh
what do you mean the URL for the
deployment
that's a URL no you shouldn't say that
you should say URI of some kind
well in this case it is a URL I know but
it might not be
number four that says four wall from
application server then in that case
it's the URL
okay fine but that should be on a
separate page like for the service uh
execute for the service connections
right the service connections list you
know Twitter is a separate thing from
you know archive is a separate thing
from pdb Etc et cetera et cetera that
same thing should be true here
of which
the thing should be service and then
within that service there is an
identifier for the this particular
deployment
correct
okay yeah
so yeah separate pages like for
interverm for example yeah right but I
think that should be a at least URI if
not just identifier or some such other
thing
is that what I'm saying yeah but I I
mean my idea in putting URL there is
that
was that
I don't want to shoehorn the names for
completely different Services into like
you know you deploy okay so for mail
receiver function what should that be
the service is
uh Services can mail receiver function
then you get it no no it's not mail
receive a function mail receiver
function is a different thing now
receiver function is what you are
deploying that right so that service is
what mail server or something Wolfram I
mean it probably is Wolfram Cloud mail
server yeah that's probably the service
I'm not sure because like
it is specific to a male receiver like
you can't
you you you're when you service connect
to the world from cloud mail server you
can't just read the mail
so I I know I know I would expect for
something that's called mail server but
it's not service connecting your service
deploying to it yeah but first before I
can service deploy I usually service
connect like all things that work in
service deploy work in service connect
maybe it's useless to service connect to
it because it's like open or wherever
but
well okay that's interesting but but I
mean you understand what I'm saying that
yeah I do I do but what I'm saying is
that it's very specific it's not just
mail server it's mail server for doing
this kind of mail receiver stuff
cloud
you know male receiver server
would be the full name I suppose
yeah
right of the service
actually is it a service because it is a
server maybe that should be
no it's server type is what it really is
is that correct
because it may be if it's all from
application server that you might have
10 of them
yes you might
so I think there's yet different things
there's a service type
then there's a particular instance of
that service type
and then there's the particular
deployment that you have out of
potentially many deployments that are
hanging off that service of that
instance of that service
so I don't understand the relationship
between that and end point
endpoint in the case so endpoint is like
URL without the base
in this case for for was
so it's it's like where you need to go
relative to the to the server
I don't think that if you scroll down
and you look at the last example you
will see what the end point is it's it's
usually like just
uh hello in this case
I think this is very obscure
you're right I just inherited it
well who who Who's uh was this Andrew's
design or whose design was this yeah I
guess Andrew and then it was implanted
by Dylan
um okay so I'm trying to bring it back
to look more like
um like Cloud deploy I think cloud
deploy is nice easy simple sure yeah
well so we need to then look I think
your point is don't standardize the
names because it's hopeless
and therefore we the name should be as
useful so to speak as possible
um you know so so in here
I don't know let's pick a random one
here
why is this so slow what's what's going
on here this is again I don't understand
what's going on
okay requests
these are not associations this is a
request type
yeah this is so I think is this
parameters what the heck is that that's
an option not a parameter
that's that's indeed strained
are you sure no I'm not sure those are
options I think that's um service when
you call service execute you always give
it a connection and then an association
yeah yeah that's the third argument but
why is that not in a string if it's key
to an association
it's really strange yeah
okay
all right let's take a look over here
um
all right what do you have here so you
have this is a telegram bot or something
yeah so I made the telegram bot uh if
you scroll up okay just to see what it
would look like and the thing is that
the there is already a packlet that does
telegram Bots
um that's been done by by this guy
curiel beloved
okay uh it's it's pretty nice but it's
like it's it's very specific to telegram
uh okay so but hold on when you say
service deploy
it's not a telegram bot you're deployed
you're deploying to Telegraph right
I am so there is the problem with
telegram Bots is that if you want to
create one you need to do it through uh
like you have to take talk to the bot
father
and you say new bot and then they'll
give you back token for that bot and
then you can set up you you have to set
stuff on their API by saying set web
hook and you point that to any URL
that's fine but I'm saying the name here
should be service deployed to telegram
not to telegram bot
[Music]
what if in okay telegram supports
different things
in this case this is a bot but there are
there's like games
which haven't even looked into which
have a different API
and so you know maybe you want to have
well then then let's call it something
like telegram bot API or
you know we should tell them about I
mean it is
it's not just telegram it's the bot part
of tell it what telegram can do oh I
understand that but if you say service
deploy telegram bot
I don't know it's it's you know what is
it it's deploying to the telegram bot
service like two things it's it's
deploying to the telegram bot API it's
deploying an API to the cloud in this
case you could deploy I got it I
understand that's what's going with all
of these cases it's what it's done with
mail receiver function as well it's
deploying a an API to the cloud and it's
deploying something to the mail so yeah
it's not all it's doing because again if
you were deploying to a wolf and web
engine instance or authen application
server instance nothing is going to the
cloud and for example you might want to
do something where for example you're
you're deploying a telegram bot but
where the API calls is on uh WWE
for example
or for example there's a there's one of
the things that uh the packlet in the
packlet repo does is to set it up just
like you did Christopher for chat GPT as
uh as a socket as a local task forever
so you you can even do that if you want
sorry
um
sorry I I spaced out for a second here
Could you um but basically just that
that you don't always the cloud is not
always involved because for example you
might deploy either there might be no
API to deploy or the API might be
deployed to something like WWE or it
might be a locally deployed thing on
like localhost
yes
but it's still visible from engine
running somewhere whether it's the cloud
or whether right well WWE it's we can
think of it in the same way
yeah it means either way I mean one it
means you need to have somebody either
specifying to which thing you want to
deploy that part or you need to be able
to First deploy that part get some API
and feed that into this other service
right okay let's take a look at this so
what does this actually look like
what is this I don't understand this
what's this
what's that look at the shorthand
version of this so in general the
structure is okay if you ignore the
first argument the second and third
arguments are like the first and second
of cloud object you either have a
shorthand that can be a string or you
have a full-fledged Cloud object or
service deployment in this case
okay but that final thing is kind of
like this is this okay look look let's
go through this again there's a service
type
or service object in case you have to
connect which is not the case here
okay but hold on hold on there's a
service type there's an instance of the
service
yeah okay
I mean like you could have multiple you
know chat Bots that are all of the same
type they're all llamas or something
they're all they're all aardvarks
whatever it is
um but there are different ones okay so
the first thing you have to say is what
type which one
what are you deploying and where are you
deploying it within that
external of that service type yeah in
the case of telegram telegram is
monolithic so you can have more I I
understand I understand there's no
private telegram it's just one Telegram
right but in other cases like well from
web engine there may be many instances
yes absolutely
Okay so
I don't know whether we've had to
address that in the service connections
business of multiple instances of the
same service type
have we
if you if you need to connect to a
specific instance you you do that with
service connect some way and then you
should take the service object that you
get from that and pass that as the first
argument so you're saying in in the
multi-instance case which includes
wolfen web engine and or from
application server you have to do a
service connect first not the yes yes
but yes yes because otherwise you don't
know where you're going unless there's
unless you have a you know dollar
cloud-based type thing which you could
have
got what I'm saying that that's the
point of the system Services function is
to allow you to specify system Services
allows you to specify what
Services
um
uh what am I saying what what services
you
um
you know which instance of a Geo server
you're going to use and so on so that's
a way that you could specify
uh you know if you just want to say well
from the application server then system
Services could let you specify which one
yeah do you get what I'm saying that's
true okay so so the the the
multi-instance thing would generally be
a service connection
unless you have specified it it's every
subject it's called
the name service object right unless you
unless you specify it and this is very
similar to external evaluate right that
you have to have
if you've specified what
you know instance of I don't know SQL or
something you're using
then you can just say external evaluate
SQL but otherwise you need to give it
a an external session object right
am I correct
mostly yeah that's I think the analogy
is good there you either give it a
string and the system looks up some
particular instance oh that this is the
pipeline in the registry in the registry
or you create a session somehow okay on
the analog of the registry here is
system Services I think
do you agree
yes I agree that that would be the place
to store that you know which what I mean
when I say welcome application server
right a particular environment like that
so the first argument is the service
which is either a service object or a
string which is resolved by the registry
second argument what you're deploying
third argument where you're deploying it
that's similar to Cloud deploy right
right
yes yeah yeah and and uh if possible the
third argument can be omitted or can be
made into a shorthand or it can be as
complicated as you wish but one
important point is when the
there are two things see this is where
it gets screwy because
okay what what does service deploy
return it Returns the service deployment
is that correct yeah not necessarily the
same as it was given because it can't
happen there's no given there's no
service deployment given there should
not be any service deployment that is
given why not
because it's totally confusing and Cloud
object can take a cloud object as Cloud
deploy can take a loud object
okay okay if you want to overwrite it if
you want to overwrite it not only it's
also useful because you can add metadata
to that that you know it's not like the
you can't commit a uuid one you can't
make up a uuid and put it there
yeah
Cloud object open close creates a uuid I
know that doesn't really exist on the
server yet
yeah I get it yeah okay but in this case
here
the
the third argument
if formatted needs it needs to tell you
where it put the thing because you don't
know it's some uuid that's why it
Returns the service deployment fine
which contains both where the server is
and where the particular service within
that server is exactly actually by the
way this would be much simpler in the
documentation service deploy there are
examples that do actually work now
rather than this you know telegram bot
thing which is kind of a toy still
so first it's this case that works now
right
all of them work now oh yeah okay but I
mean
that's a service object
service deploy
I don't like this this doesn't seem
right
maybe it's right
um but but the the one above where it's
just a string
is much simpler and easier I I don't
know why the like the design of was
wants you to specify the resource
explicitly even if it's like in the end
it's not exposed so you can store all
the resources as whatever as as your
ideas because you never see them
right I don't know whether there is this
distinction in fact in more from web
engine there isn't
um
okay okay okay hold on that
all right let's come back
I mean there's some cleanup then for for
an application server for its
specification but let's look at some of
these other ones and we're going to run
out of time
so here
service deploy to Alexa
what the heck is all this stuff
no
this is this is we were just
brainstorming about what service deploy
would look like if applied to my
Alexa packlet
okay the remember the second argument is
what you are deploying
right okay
right but this in effect is what you're
deploying because you don't the the
the Alexa code Alexa packed with code
builds the API function for you from
this specification which is a list of
Handler groups so in effect this is what
you are deploying it's just a it's just
a very simple way to specify without
actually having to write an API function
that API function gets created for you
that that I mean that's also why that's
under the header curated like for Alexa
if you were to write every time the API
function on your own you'd have a lot of
boilerplate
and we take like what's the value added
no I understand that but I understand
but so what you're saying is this is a
case in which
whereas with the telegram bot or mail
receiver function as soon as you go to
that mail endpoint it is hooking back it
is calling into the cloud with a
particular API function
the case that we have here is something
much closer to our URL what's it called
URL bundle what the heck is that thing
called a URL dispatcher not not white
because the intents then will have all
sorts of keywords that you have to set
up on the Alexa side first
but yeah I mean but the point is it's a
multi-headed that there may be multiple
API functions no no there's just one API
function that acts but it has its own
dispatching logic to these different
intents there's just one endpoint in the
cloud for handling this skill
this just is just a very concise way of
letting you specify the minimum amount
of information you know which intent
gets which gets handling which function
is it and what happens is a large pages
long API function effectively is written
for you that
handles but basically let me just give
the hierarchy again okay the hierarchy
is service type
I wish this was in Dropbox but anyway
service type service instance so this
service service server
basically
then
uh
deployment instance
and then
subpart of deployment
is that correct
it is correct but not all of the
services will have all of these parts
right I know that I know that I'm trying
to understand what is the hierarchy here
oh that's that's correct
okay
so in other words this is effectively a
bundle of apis
that's what that's doing the sub part is
labeling the different parts of a bundle
of apis
yeah pretty much
okay
and the deployment instance
okay so I'm going to claim that we
really shouldn't have it looking like
this that what we should do is service
deploy should have as a convention that
it can have an association as its second
argument where the right hand side of
the association is always API functions
well what would I put here I I I don't
want to put an API function here but
what do you want to do what is that
function what is this function that
function is a function that handles one
specific
request one specific utterance that you
might make so it's a function you're
just giving the actual raw code that
runs given that reference exactly
does it have an argument or does it just
yes it gets arguments as slot values
from yeah it has arguments the the the
arguments are determined by how you set
this skill up in the Alexa portal okay
so what we're saying is that every
service has a harness and it's going to
take the second argument and when the
service is is called it's going to take
the second argument apply the harness
I'm not sure the harness is the right
term here
and then call it in other words no
that's not really right because the
harness if you're thinking about the
harnesses being something that runs on
the Alexa side that harness is is at the
moment has to be specified manually on
the Alexa's site but that harness goes
in the third argument in the service
deployment business this is literally
the API function this is just just think
of this as another way to specify an API
function except without having to
specify the details of the API function
I think another helpful way of seeing
this is like if you if you put an API
function in the second argument for for
cloud deploy sorry in the first targeted
boy it can modify the literal code that
is in there picking up definitions and
stuff like that this is a more complex
transformation of that code
which is context dependent and so on and
so forth but for it's not always
necessarily an API function because for
example the telegram Bots have a Json
payload in the body so they don't have
parameters per se
you have to parse or another uh
yeah or another one is if you go to the
chat gbt plugins you don't give a name
you know the end points take many
parameters more than an API function
because they need prompt information
then maybe I shouldn't have written it
that's API functions but okay
but maybe there are enough options the
API functions that you can pretend but
yeah like you can hide it in the
appearance rules or something but uh
yeah okay but that's exactly the the
thing we got into with male receiver
function where you're hiding things in
metadata
and it's a mess
so let's look at this cases is this real
this service deploy of chat GPT no no
it's not it's not just trying to imagine
how the thing that that Chris wrote
would look like in this Brave New World
where we split like the metadata such as
prompt description and so on from the
actual functions
okay so these are the end points which
are referred to in the prompt basically
and their API functions in this case
well yeah so the the top example is the
real one although it's a little ugly
looking because you use packet symbols
but yeah but but the uh right so you can
see that there's there's you know each
each function needs a name uh which I
guess is encoded with this Association
here it can also optionally take a
prompt that's associated with each
function so you could say you know this
is the get to Do's then you could have a
prompt that says use this function when
you want to get the list of to-do's
um
you know and then there's also
um there's also prompting for each
argument which you can encode with the
help parameter an API function
uh
yeah yeah
okay we're not going to get this solved
in this instant we're going to have to
continue this because I have to go to
something different in a moment here
um but Stephen can we just back up to
the overall we're just trying to get
your approval I want to change to the
argument sequence of service deploy to
make it more generalized and the point
of this was just demonstrate multiple
cases how they're they're different from
each other that in fact Carlos proposed
argument sequence makes sense sequences
what service you're putting it what
service instance you're putting it into
first argument
yeah second argument
what thing you're lodging there
yeah that's the Wolfram language it's
the Wolfram language thing that runs
right not not the thing that's being
lodged in there this is typically being
launched in the cloud or in walk from no
it's not being lodged in the cloud it's
got as you pointed out the Alexa skill
and so on that entirely runs on the
walking cloud side no I I get it but I'm
going to point out there's a little bit
of a problem here okay remember this
hierarchy service type service and you
know service server
and then
sort of sub case within that server like
you are you know like a cloud object on
the cloud right on a particular cloud
Okay the third argument that you have
is the description of the
sort of of the particular deployment
like the particular Cloud object the
particular mail
you know mail address those kinds of
things am I making sense no yeah I think
that is that right it's the third
argument the third argument is argument
third argument is the best specific
location within the particular service
right that's information about the
service the second argument is
information about what happens on the
open language side I know but I'm
pointing out your first and third
arguments are both information about the
service which is different from cloud
deploy because Cloud deploy takes a
cloud-based option that is the analog of
your first argument here
rule that is true but on the other hand
I think that uh it's it also follows
like the third argument in many cases
can be completely omitted
I get it I I get it but I'm I'm making
it back to the first
what well I'm saying that you could you
could combine the third argument into
the first argument because I think that
border is is fuzzy
you know what's on a different instance
of the application server versus what's
an end point within that so can you look
at the first use example under service
deploy in the second notebook you have
there no on the other notebook the
documentation notebook
like this thing where you do service
deploy the was service connect object
and then just API function is somewhere
like yeah it's good that's good but I
mean you can do that
the um
you know
you can do that anyway if if the first
the anonymous case is easy to deal with
the case that is not so easy which I
claim should be put into the first
argument not split across first and
third argument is the specific
destination within the server
right if the specific destination within
the server is automatic
that means create your own place uuid up
your own place
to go what I'm saying
yeah but I I I don't understand like in
most cases the first argument like
contains the the the you know the
connection the login and password stuff
you cannot deal without it right yeah so
so it it is really and also like service
deployment well then I think you should
have an optional second argument
because I think it's wrong to split
between the first and third argument the
you know you've got the server that's
the first argument the server and
authentication to get to the server
another argument is on that server where
is which pigeonhole are you putting this
in
see what I'm saying
which I'm not I'm not that convinced
because I I think most cases like the
the the service connection is something
you put in a variable it's very short in
theory did you listen to what I said I'm
saying the service connection first
argument the service object okay that
specifies this server how you get to it
it's authentication all those kinds of
things the second thing you need to
specify is which pigeonhole you are
using on the server
I mean the cloud object name the the
male you know the mail ID the the skill
name you know I don't know what it is
the the the the the
um yeah I get it but what I'm saying is
that if you do that
and the main case I wanted to cater to
is someone who has written their first
app on the cloud with Cloud deploy and
then they would just want to go and
search and replace in the code Cloud
deploy with service deploy you have WWE
comma
and that just keeps working because it's
the same argument structure and they get
the same
apparently okay so you're saying you're
proposing the first argument is the
server
the second argument is the thing you're
deploying and the third argument is the
pigeonhole actually ideally what I would
what I really like is service deploy
being service deploy open close the
server and then the other arguments like
it's it's uh likes you can replace
service deploy of WWE
and and Cloud deploy
like you know
I think that's a little weird yeah I
know but
so I mean the main point is remember
with three things server
payload pigeonhole
makes sense to really agree that those
are the three things we're dealing with
here
yeah and do we all agree also that
pigeon Hall in many cases can be
automatic and so absolutely pigeonhole
can be omitted and the pigeon will find
its own home but the payload never so
having them as swapping them from what
they are here is weird to me because
yeah well fair enough
I'm just a little concerned that the
first and third arguments are going to
have things that are very shared
and I don't like the fact that the
service deployment
could go in the third argument I think
that's totally weird because the service
deployment is going to contain a service
object I I think that in 99 of the cases
you're gonna have you're gonna just
refer to and I don't know how well it
works this right now but if you have if
you are connected to One World from
application server then probably you
don't need to repeat yeah
let me make a suggestion if the third
argument
if you have a full service deployment
you simply put it in the first argument
and it contains the pigeonhole as well
you got what I'm saying don't put in
other words you could either have a
service deployment that has everything
the server and the pigeonhole
right just not the payload
in which case you put that in the first
argument if you are separately
specifying the server and the pigeonhole
you can put those in the respectively
the first and third arguments
well another version would say that the
pigeon hole should go in the the thing
that you're deploying
because at some level sometimes it's
it's it's like
you know the idea that there is a
pigeonhole at all is a little bit vague
well okay so so you might argue with
this option to the service right but but
then the argument that you're giving
there is maybe you're deploying multiple
things at a time that go in different
pigeon holes and how do you deal with
that
but like I'll give you an example right
so suppose you're deploying something
you know like to AWS Lambda like so I
mean you're deploying something it's
like an API function you know but but
maybe it has a name associated with it
does that mean that the pigeonhole let's
say the name of the you know of the path
you should go to call the API or is that
path just an argument to the deployment
no it's right I think it's an argument
because the the point is that if you
keep the name but change the payload you
want to be able to overwrite it
that's what you do with Cloud object for
example
like I really need to go um but the you
guys can continue if you want but but um
I really need to go
um and uh
well do we need to
we probably need to continue as well
we're seeking a resolution on this just
we're getting close we've defined it
pretty well what the issue is let's
let's see if we can just make sure we
can distinguish between server and
pigeonhole and how that works server
pigeonhole and payload right and you
didn't like the idea that the server and
the pigeonhole are separated as first
and third arguments I'm concerned that
that's not going to work and then
Christopher is pointing out that the
payload is also mixed with the
pigeonhole that that's that
I don't know I I think that like we are
sacrificed like 95 of the case you're
connected to one thing at a time
and you don't care about changing the
server that much you just care about
whether you're well that's what we did
that's what we did for cloud objects
right for cloud objects we have a
service you know a cloud-based we could
have a service base too
yeah but and I think that it kind of
works automatically if you're connected
to only one world from application
survey you can just take more
communication server as the first
argument just the type yeah well maybe
maybe but I mean but clearly you can't
get away without the first argument just
like for external evaluate because you
need to say what kind of a thing no is
it
you know what
so I think this requires a little bit
more thought and I need to go so okay
okay
bye everyone